foreign
let me just rewind back to
um last spring
I told you that before the midterms that
Biden would announce some kind of debt
forgiveness program just in time to
influence the midterms
and that he would and that when you
looked into the details of the program
you would see that it didn't amount to
much but that they would make a big
splash like they had really done
something
and they did exactly that
and everyone's talking about Biden for
giving the student loans Biden for
giving the student loans right up into
the midterms and you notice no one's
talked about it since the election
and he came out real quietly this week
and said well you know we're going to
suspend the forgiveness program
uh until the court rules on it because
the sixth circuit court is now put a
permanent stay on it until there's an
actual court case involved it's not a no
longer a temporary stay they've just put
the quietus on this thing and the debt
forgiveness program so
yeah yeah Dave as I was reading this
last night I had the thought how did
Dave know like you have called it at
every stop along the way so it's what I
would have done if I were a politician
with no principles it's exactly what I
would have done because it was logical
it makes sense it was it was a very
shrewd political move
no intention whatsoever no expectation
whatsoever that the loans would actually
ever be forgiven did not notify the
Department of Education did not notify a
student dot eight dot was student go to
studentloan.gov.gov studentaid.gov major
part of the administration's
function to forgive the student loans
didn't even tell them ahead of time I
mean if you're going to roll out a
program that's going to affect tens of
millions of people you've got to get
your staff ready for this
no notice to them whatsoever and then
announces it and that tells us right
there that you know you didn't think
it's going to go through I think it's
just hard to believe that like these are
real people's lives this is you know a
generation learning to relate to money
and learning responsibility with money
and to think that they could just you
know have all this confusion and kind of
be played with because political part be
manipulated by politicians oh you're so
sweet you never thought that would
happen I didn't want to believe it would
happen Dave
it's happening yeah and uh so federal
student loan bills have been scheduled
to resume in January of course they're
going to have trouble getting through a
house that is now a majority Republican
it's not going to happen so he and of
course then he gets the the next shrewd
move is watch this it's gonna the I
tried to do it I tried but the Mino
Republicans wouldn't let me that's
that's coming next that's the thing so
Biden Administration on Tuesday
announced it will extend the payment
pause because it is the one thing they
can do on federal student loans until
after June because you should never have
to pay your bills because there's
inflation that I caused
no that isn't what they said was it okay
no that wasn't what they said uh top
official at the education department
recently said student loan default rates
could dramatically Spike if its loan
forgiveness program is supported you
think yeah there ain't nobody paying
these things so the way we're not going
to admit that this uh this uh head fake
on the get forgiveness thing cause
everybody to stop paying
uh we're just gonna not make you pay
until June so that it doesn't show up
and by then you'll forget that the
reason the student loan default rates
went way up was because we told
everybody we were going to forgive them
and then we didn't oh that's that yeah
nice moves nice move so what does all
this tell you
man it's been interesting it it it's
confusing that's what it really tells
you right now it's it's kind of unfair
and confusing I actually asked a
question on Instagram last night
um just trying to get people's feelings
on it and the range is so wide it's what
was most interesting to me is even
people with student loans who are paying
off student loans are starting to get
frustrated they're like just give us
clear guidance let us know what to
expect this back and forth this it's
going to be forgiven and yet wait all of
this is just so confusing and people are
getting really frustrated
didn't see this I just saw it in the
article
I thought they were extending the
payment because Economic Times were so
bad no
the education secretary Cardona says in
a statement we're extending the payment
pause because it would be deeply unfair
to ask borrowers to pay a debt that they
wouldn't have to pay if it wasn't for
the baseless lawsuits brought by
Republicans
I told you they were gonna blame them
yeah we're gonna we're we're gonna just
not make you pay payments because the
amino Republicans are not going to let
us do the Forgiveness thing that's what
she just said
dang
ouch okay moral of the story is this if
you wait on this clown show yep
both sides of the aisles together you
couldn't make a good circus if you mix
the whole thing in a stew pot okay if
you wait on this clown show if you wait
on the Island of Misfit Toys it's called
Washington DC to fix your life your life
is always going to suck
if you're waiting on a government
program to make your life shiny
your life's gonna suck
it's not their job
it's not within their power
to make your life awesome it is within
your power
absolutely and so here's a plan you took
out the loan
pay it back
you owe it
I don't know it I didn't take it out and
I'm a taxpayer and I shouldn't have to
pay your loan
a guy who
is a welder and didn't go to college and
makes 85 000 a year and work 60 hours a
week and he's out there in Sub-Zero
temperatures somewhere in North America
right now welding a building together
for you to sit your little butt in
shouldn't have to pay your student loan
that's not fair
wow mic drop something to think about
but I will say if you have student loans
right now and you hear this wake-up call
and you're going man I don't want to
wait on Washington I hate this feeling
of confusion and you want to get ready
to just attack these loans this is a
great time to do it there's no interest
there's no interest pile on this is not
the time to not pay it's the time to pay
exactly they gave you more time interest
free this is a blessing in that regard
you have time without interest occurring
to pay off these student loans yeah